and joining me now with reaction to my
open and so much more as a host of
tucker carlson tonight the one and only
tucker carlson how are you tucker am i
wrong
well i'm just i'm sitting here stunned
by the craven suck-uppery of stephen
colbert every time i see it it just
the synapses in my brain
cease um
you're not wrong i mean this is the most
cynical anti-democratic exercise in the
history of american politics i mean
biden
got into the race it was clear to
everyone around him including members of
his family that he wasn't up for it he
was grieving understandably the death of
his son beau
and so he ran for president for the
third time and got no popular support
essentially none he was an afterthought
bernie sanders rose to the top of the
pack bernie sanders was very close to
getting the nomination for the second
cycle
right and the democratic establishment
deeply threatened controlled by big
banks by finance decided we have to
align to knock this guy out and so once
again they did just that and they
decided biden in a kind of brilliant
move that went right over my head as
someone who's covered politics for 30
years decided biden was the perfect
vessel for their ambitions now if you
believe in democracy you think will
people elect a president because they
believe in that president his character
his views his commitment to them et
cetera et cetera it's about this guy
right it's about the chief executive
their understanding was it doesn't
really matter who the person is as long
as he is an able spokesman a marionette
on behalf
of the oligarchy that actually runs the
country so they sort of made it explicit
unfortunately
trump
was so disliked by democratic voters
that a lot of them i think understood
kind of what was going on on a gut level
but went along with it because at least
he wasn't trump
and so
this guy got elected with less popular
support than any president in our
history by far through a kind of series
of circumstantial quirks and here we are
and it's and they they understood
brilliantly it's it is hard to attack
joe biden because you look at him first
of all you know a lot of people know i
mean i've known joe biden for decades
and joe biden is like a very friendly
guy you know he's wrong on everything
but he's like a friendly person and then
you look at him now and he's so clearly
diminished and you feel bad for him it's
kind of hard to attack him exactly but
you know tougher
you feel badly for him but you know he
is the president of the united states
he's taking advantage of the american
people by saying i can do this he
doesn't answer questions it appears that
the military the fbi the doj are
operating separate from him
so you know we shouldn't feel bad for
him we should feel bad for ourselves
someone who is a vessel and i'm filled
with self-pity about it every day trust
me
i'm just saying
as a
face of an oligarchical takeover of our
system which is what he is you couldn't
really pick a better one
because on some level you know you kind
of can't blame him because he doesn't
really know what's going on now if susan
rice or barack obama or ron klainer the
people who are actually running things
were at the front you could look at ron
clayne and say actually you're a you're
a terrible illegitimate president who's
trying to destroy the country you
inherited but with biden you're mad at
him but you're also like i feel bad
because he literally has dementia so how
angry can you be at him it's just it's
brilliant as
as
as something that's been forced on the
public like if you wanted to pick a
cutout through whom you ran the country
you'd pick biden but but even more
brilliant is the fact that people are
almost locked in in terms of not doing
anything because they know the option is
kamala harris that nobody likes i mean i
mean i i how could someone be that that
that vapid and i mean even the ad she
did for oh you can see with your eyes
the space the moon
come on well that's right and she again
is like the living embodiment of what
biden is which is a middle finger to the
idea of democracy kamal harris got
elected to the senate in a state that
doesn't have a functioning democracy
it's a one-party state so the democratic
party can put up anybody kamala harris
as you pointed out just a minute ago was
deeply unpopular among democrats in
california but they're reflexive voters
so she got elected so like nobody likes
commonwealth hair she has no record of
achievement whatsoever she's deeply
mediocre and fragile and like everything
about is awful but she's still the most
powerful fully conscious person in the
u.s government is that democracy once
again i mean i'm starting to sound naive
but if you grew up in this country as i
did for 50 years thinking it's kind of
real it's not totally responsive to the
public but basically the public gets to
choose its own leaders the last five
years has proven no that's not true if
you elect somebody that they don't like
like they destroy him
if you right i mean mike we're not
really in charge mike flynn is the guy
that obama hated and it continued even
during the trump administration which
made it clear with a judge on the bench
saying basically i'm going to throw my
robe off i'm going to get down there as
a prosecutor and prosecute him for
treason he's not charged with treason so
it's it's almost like all of these
people are still there so can the
american people have confidence in this
man as president oh and and it's so it's
just funny i think i'm pretty surp i i
flatter myself i'm sophisticated about
politics but but i'm not really because
it took me years to figure out what
happened with mike flynn it took me many
months to figure out that joe biden was
actually going to be the nominee and he
could get elected because it's just so
different from the way american politics
has ever functioned so the truth about
mike flynn and again i plead guilty to
missing this for years
is that trump gets elected but he's not
really in charge of the executive branch
of government the hundreds of thousands
of federal employees who still
effectively report to barack obama so
you can change the name of the guy
running things but you don't change
the people running things obama was
still in charge in a lot of ways
in early 2017. that's not democracy
that's a permanent ruling class that
runs everything without regard to what
voters want i mean that's just really
scary and it's hard to internalize that
if you believe in the basic american
ideals but it's true well it is true and
you know for someone like me i put 32
years in law enforcement and i said if
there are no prosecutions of all of
these individuals who lied to congress
who repeatedly who you know who had
classified information on their emails
and and you know where a normal guy goes
to jail
you know then i have to i have to
question what did i do for 30 years
exactly because justice should be the
same for everyone and i'm i'm just i'm
becoming more and more disillusioned and
i want someone to come back and and say
don't be disillusioned janine this is
still america is it
well what is america i mean america as a
system is above all else above even our
market economy in our robust you know
standard of living america is equal
treatment under the law the federal
government treats all citizens as
citizens regardless of who their parents
were or how they look or who they voted
for everybody is equal under the law
that's the core promise of the country
so if you undo that
then what are you left with actually not
much and i hate to say it it's not just
one example you know the president's son
commits a federal gun felony and has
never charged for it right
it's not just that you know you get to
shoot ashley babbitt with a you know a
cop with a history a documented history
of reckless behavior and no one calls
you to account for it it's like a
thousand examples and here's the bottom
line opponents of the regime are
punished
allies of the regime are not so you can
literally loot macy's in midtown
manhattan and you're fine okay but if
you try to defend your own property with
a gun as happened to that couple in st
louis you're indicted because you're not
voting for biden it's that simple tucker
i love hearing from you we're up against
a break thank you so much for being with
us tonight thank you judge all right hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else